no like does it does it um because the
question i had
was you've had a very varied career in
terms of like everything you do now when
i when i've reading
when i was reading up you you're like a
streamer you're a cosplayer you're a
writer
you've done a lot of things but how's
your career in the um
japanese adult video industry has that
like affected
how people view you in when you're doing
other things at all
mia i mean i appreciate people
like started knowing me because of jv
like i
still keep the same name because that's
the name like people
know me yeah i'm like i appreciate
that like for that because of that
experience i get the light more
like i get to speak more yeah you get to
have an interesting conversation because
of that experience
but i don't want to be like just
like forever people just forever see me
as jb yeah
yeah like even though like i'm retired
but it just doesn't matter yeah
yeah yeah because i think uh uh mia
khalifa recently
uh she had like i think was it like a
breakdown on twitter or on instagram
i remember reading up about it where she
actually regrets
working in porn because of how it just
completely dehumanized her and
affected her in a way that she can never
recover
so i guess for you have you ex have you
ever thought that you've regretted
that career at all the reason i'm
right now i'm not making an only fan
account like i'm not doing anything yeah
because i want to redeem myself not as a
jv actually as a past or
current yeah because i want to have a
second career like i want to show
people that you don't have to keep
taking off your clothes just because you
did it once
yeah yeah that's why like i'm encouraged
to do this like
yeah just being myself and that's like
that's how why i have like so much
respect for you because
anybody else would change their name you
know yeah after jav right because
they think they're like oh no like
people if they see that name
people are only going to remember me for
that thing yeah but the fact that you
didn't just goes to show that like
no i can i can grow out of this right
like i'm confident
enough in myself that i'll be able to
sell myself as a person
yeah and not just like the person that
once used to do porn right like that's
i don't know that's that's really cool
that's big dick energy
my past like i'm not ashamed of it i'm
not necessarily proud of it like i've
never
been proud of what i do like as a
newspaper reporter or
as a teacher like if you're i mean some
actress actresses say like oh we're
helping
japan to have a low crime rate low sex
crime rate or something you know
but maybe it's true but i guess if
you're doing any kind of jobs like
you're helping somebody
in a way yeah yeah you don't really have
to be proud of it so yeah of course of
course yeah you're working so
yeah so i'm not necessarily proud of it
but i am proud of it that i'm
kind of growing out of it yeah it was a
stepping stone for me i'm not doing the
same thing
like i do wear a sexy round treat or
maybe
sexy cosplay you know but i'm not
showing anything more
yeah yeah yeah right i'm not you know
making a
secret account like to show more people
can subscribe and you take a few more
you don't have enough i don't do that
you just did it again yeah exactly